en los pueblos Hopi en Arizona,
las casas de piedra rojiza en Nueva York,
las casas de madera en San Francisco.
Estos no son palacios o catedrales.
Son solo residencias corrientes
que expresan el esplendor de lo común en las ciudades.
Y la razón por la que son así es que la necesidad de cobijo
está muy ligada al deseo humano por la belleza.
Sus superficies ásperas crean una ciudad táctil.
¿Cierto? Calles que Uds. pueden leer
pasando los dedos por encima del ladrillo y la piedra.
Pero eso se hace cada vez más difícil,
porque las ciudades se están volviendo suaves.
De los nuevos centros urbanos brotan torres
casi siempre hechas de hormigón y acero y cubiertos en vidrio.
Se ve en el paisaje urbano en todo el mundo:
Houston,
Guangzhou,
Frankfurt,
donde se ve el mismo ejército de robots de acabado brillante
erguido hacia el horizonte.
Ahora, solo piensen en todo lo que perdemos
cuando los arquitectos dejan de usar
la gama completa de materiales disponibles.
Cuando rechazamos el granito, la piedra caliza, la piedra arenisca,
la madera, el cobre, la terracota, el ladrillo
el adobe y el yeso,
simplificamos la arquitectura y empobrecemos las ciudades.
Es como si redujeran todas las gastronomías del mundo
a la comida de las líneas aéreas.
(Risas)
¿Pollo o pasta?
Pero peor aún,
conjuntos de torres de vidrio como ésta en Moscú
parecen menospreciar los aspectos cívicos y comunitarios de la vida urbana.
Estos edificios están destinados
a enriquecer a sus propietarios e inquilinos,
pero no necesariamente las vidas del resto de nosotros,
aquellos de nosotros que usamos los espacios entre los edificios.
Y esperamos hacerlo de forma gratuita.
Las torres brillantes son una especie invasora
que ahogan nuestras ciudades y eliminan el espacio público.
Tendemos a pensar en una fachada como si fuera maquillaje,
una capa decorativa aplicada al finalizar un edificio una vez completo.
Pero solo porque una fachada es superficial
no significa que no sea también profunda.
Permítanme darles un ejemplo
de cómo las superficies de una ciudad afectan a los que vivimos en ella.
Cuando visité Salamanca en España,
acababa en la Plaza Mayor
a todas horas del día.
Temprano por la mañana, la luz del sol se refleja en las fachadas
formando sombras
y por la noche, la luz de los focos segmenta los edificios
en cientos de áreas distintas:
balcones, ventanas y pórticos,
cada uno un apartado separado de actividad visual.
Aquellos detalles e intensidades, aquel glamour
da a la plaza un toque teatral.
Se convierte en una escena donde las generaciones pueden reunirse.
Se ven adolescentes sentados en los adoquines,
mayores que monopolizan los bancos,
y la vida real empieza a parecerse a un marco de ópera.
El telón se levanta en Salamanca.
Así que, porque estoy hablando solo de los exteriores de los edificios
y no de la forma, la función, o la estructura,
aún así, esas superficies forman el tejido de nuestras vidas,
porque los edificios crean los espacios de su alrededor
y esos espacios pueden atraer o ahuyentar a la gente.
Y la diferencia a menudo tiene que ver con la calidad de los exteriores.
Así que un sinónimo contemporáneo de la Plaza Mayor en Salamanca
es la Plaza de la Defensa en París,
un espacio abierto con paredes de vidrio por donde los empleados se apresuran pasar
de camino desde el metro a sus cubículos
y donde pasan el menos tiempo posible.
A principios de los 80 el arquitecto Philip Johnson
trató de recrear una bonita plaza europea en Pittsburgh.
Esta es PPG Place,
un espacio abierto de 22 000 m2 rodeado de edificios comerciales
hechos de vidrio reflectante.
Y él adornó esos edificios con molduras metálicas
y torretas góticas
que cubren el horizonte.
Pero a nivel del suelo,
la plaza parece una jaula de cristal negro.
Quiero decir, claro, en verano
los niños corren hacia la fuente
y hay patinaje sobre hielo en el invierno,
pero carece de la informalidad de un rato tranquilo.
No es el lugar donde realmente se quiere pasar el rato y charlar.
Los espacios públicos prosperan o fallan por muchas razones diferentes.
Su arquitectura es solo una razón,
pero una importante.
Algunas plazas recientes
como La Federation Square en Melbourne
o la Superkilen en Copenhague
tienen éxito porque combinan lo antiguo con lo nuevo,
lo áspero con lo liso,
los colores neutros con los brillantes
y porque no se basan excesivamente en el vidrio.
No tengo nada contra el vidrio.
Es un material antiguo y versátil.
Es fácil de fabricar, transportar,
instalar, reemplazar
y limpiar.
Y se fabrican desde hojas enormes, ultra transparentes
a ladrillos translúcidos.
Nuevos recubrimientos hacen que cambie de apariencia
con la luz cambiante.
En ciudades caras como Nueva York, tiene el poder mágico
de poder subir su valor inmobiliario ya que permite tener vistas,
que es realmente la única cosa que los desarrolladores tienen que ofrecer
para justificar esos precios surrealistas.
A mediados del siglo XIX,
con la construcción del Palacio de Cristal en Londres,
el vidrio saltó a la cabeza de la lista de materiales esencialmente modernos.
A mediados del siglo XX,
llegó a dominar los centros de algunas ciudades estadounidenses
en gran parte debido a algunos edificios de oficinas realmente espectaculares
como Lever House en el centro de Manhattan,
diseñado por Skidmore, Owings y Merrill.
Finalmente, la tecnología avanzó hasta el punto
donde los arquitectos podían diseñar estructuras tan transparentes
que prácticamente no se veían.
Y en el camino,
el vidrio se convirtió en el material por defecto de la ciudad de gran altura,
y hay una razón muy poderosa para eso.
Porque a medida que la población global se congrega en las ciudades,
los menos afortunados viven apretados en barrio de viviendas precarias.
Pero cientos de millones de personas
necesitan apartamentos y lugares para trabajar
en edificios cada vez más grandes,
por lo que tiene sentido económico levantar agujas de cristal
y envolverlas en muros baratos con cortinas prácticas.
Pero el vidrio tiene una capacidad limitada
de expresión.
Esta es una sección de pared que enmarca una plaza
en la ciudad prehispánica de Mitla, en el sur de México.
Esas tallas de 2000 años de antigüedad
han dejado claro que este era un lugar con alto significado ritual.
Hoy nos fijamos en ellas y podemos ver una continuidad histórica y de texturas
entre esas tallas, las montañas de alrededor
y aquella iglesia que se levanta sobre las ruinas
construida con piedras saqueadas del lugar.
En la cercana Oaxaca, incluso los edificios de yeso
se convierten en lienzos
para colores brillantes, murales políticos y sofisticadas artes gráficas.
Es un lenguaje intrincado y comunicativo
que una epidemia de vidrio simplemente no puede borrar.
La buena noticia es que arquitectos y desarrolladores
han comenzado a redescubrir las alegrías de la textura
sin alejarse de la modernidad.
Algunos encuentran usos innovadores para materiales antiguos como el ladrillo
y la terracota.
Otros inventan nuevos productos como los paneles moldeados
que Snøhetta usó
para dar al Museo de Arte Moderno de San Francisco
esa apariencia ondulada, escultural.
El arquitecto Stefano Boeri incluso creó fachadas vivas.
Este es su Bosque Vertical,
un par de torres de apartamentos en Milán,
cuya característica más visible es la vegetación.
Y Boeri está diseñando una versión de este para Nanjing en China.
Imagínense si las fachadas verdes fueran tan ubicuas como las de vidrio
cúan más limpio sería el aire en las ciudades chinas.
Pero la verdad es que estos proyectos son en su mayoría únicos,
proyectos de boutique,
no se reproducen fácilmente a escala global.
Y ese es el problema.
Cuando se usan materiales que tienen un significado local,
eso impide que las ciudades se vean igual.
El cobre tiene una larga historia en Nueva York...
La Estatua de la Libertad,
la corona del Edificio Woolworth...
Pero hacía mucho tiempo que no estaba de moda
hasta que los arquitectos lo usaron para cubrir el American Copper Building,
un par de torres torcidas en el East River.
Ni siquiera está terminado y se puede ver la manera
cómo la puesta de sol ilumina esa fachada metálica,
que se volverá verde a medida que envejece.
Los edificios pueden ser como la gente.
Sus caras reflejan sus experiencias.
Y eso es un punto importante,
porque cuando el vidrio envejece,
solo lo reemplazas
y el edificio se ve casi de la misma manera que antes
hasta que finalmente se demuele.
Casi todos los demás materiales tienen la capacidad
de absorber trozos de historia y recuerdos
y proyectarlos en el presente.
La empresa Ennead revistió
el Museo de Historia Natural de Utah en Salt Lake City en cobre y zinc,
minerales que han sido extraídos de la zona durante 150 años
y que también camuflan el edificio contra las colinas de color ocre
para que tengas un museo de historia natural
que refleja la historia natural de la región.
Y cuando el chino Wang Shu ganador del Premio Pritzker
estaba construyendo un museo de historia en Ningbo,
no estaba creando un simple envoltorio para el pasado
sino construyendo memoria directamente en las paredes
usando ladrillos y piedras y tejas
rescatadas de los pueblos que habían sido demolidos.
Ahora, los arquitectos pueden usar el vidrio
de manera igualmente lírica e inventiva.
Aquí en Nueva York, dos edificios,
uno de Jean Nouvel y éste de Frank Gehry
se enfrentan en West 19th Street,
y el juego de luces que producen
es como una sinfonía en la luz.
Pero cuando una ciudad prefiere el vidrio,
a medida que crece
se convierte en una sala de espejos,
inquietante y fría.
Después de todo, las ciudades concentran la diversidad
y son lugares donde las culturas del mundo y las lenguas y los estilos de vida
se juntan y se mezclan.
Así que en lugar de encerrar toda esa variedad y diversidad
en edificios aplastantemente iguales
deberíamos tener una arquitectura
que honre toda la gama de la experiencia urbana.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)